han pasado casi tres semanas desde las
elecciones y donald trump ha mantenido
el mismo enfoque desde el primer día
la industria farmacéutica invirtió
millones de dólares en publicidad
negativa en contra durante la campaña la
cual gané teníamos a la gran
farmacéutica en contra a los medios a la
gran tecnología en contra a la
deshonestidad en contra las artesanas
gigantes
después de gioia y michigan la decepción
vino de pensilvania para la campaña de
trump donde un juez federal desestimó
una demanda que pretendía tirar millones
de votos por correo algunos consejeros
le han animado a encontrar una salida
digna pero el presidente se ha negado a
ceder una actitud que sigue inflamando a
su núcleo republicano en plena pandemia
[Música]
creo que hay un problema con nuestro
sistema electoral y en todo caso todo el
mundo debería estar de acuerdo en que
hay un problema y creo que un recuento
total debería hacerse en persona con
identificación es la única manera de
hacer que ambas partes puedan aceptar el
reto
a menos de un mes del voto convocado por
el colegio electoral se siguen
celebrando en el país marchas y
protestas en el bando trompista los más
escépticos frente al coronavirus desde
el día de las elecciones el número de
nuevos contagios no bajó de los 100.000
diarios llegando hasta casi 200 mil el
viernes eeuu sobre pasó este fin de
semana la barra de los 12 millones de
casos ya lleva más de 255 mil decesos de
comida en el mismo tiempo el presidente
electo joe biden habló de la necesidad
de llevar máscara como de un deber
patriótico